today on the matt welsh show a serial
killer was released twice from prison
and then killed each time again the
story only gets crazier from there and
more infuriating from there and it's
part of a deeper cultural trend that
goes beyond the justice system that i
want to talk about today also antifa
plans to disrupt my event at georgia
tech tonight so that'll be fun plus the
us air force brags about its lgbtq
initiatives while war rages in europe
and a tennis player cries after being
heckled by somebody in the audience this
emotional display of course means that
she is courageous the media tells us and
finally daily cancellation we'll discuss
the kim and kanye drama it's not just
celebrity gossip i mean it is that but
there's something
more going on here that we'll talk about
as well all of that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
you know mortgage rates continue to
remain incredibly low will they stay
this way throughout the year though well
it's not likely
we know that everything seems to be
going up these days and that's why you
need to call american financing lock
into a low rate now potentially save
yourself up to a thousand dollars a
month that's 12 000 a year and at this
rate that'll be enough to fill up you
know one tank of gas but you got to take
the savings whenever you can find it
think about how much that it could help
to save money and then give american
financing a call there's no pressure no
obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation around ways
to save big money without starting your
loan over either so you're just you're
getting in you're getting this done
instead you can choose any um term 10
years and over whatever makes sense for
your budget and your future it's really
that simple and you're saving money just
do so now while rates are still low it
only takes 10 minute call to learn more
and if you start soon you can skip two
mortgage payments and may close in as
fast as 10 days so call 866 569 4711
that's 866 569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmlsconsumeraccess.org
we begin on a monday with an
extraordinarily disturbing story that
only gets worse or worse as you as you
begin to peel back the layers of the
putrid onion
but there's a reason we're beginning
here and it's it's not just for shock
value and i'll explain in a minute but
first the new york times reports this an
83 year old brooklyn woman convicted
twice of killing women she lived with
was charged with murder on thursday
after investigators found a head in her
apartment that officials said belonged
to a body discovered in a shopping cart
last week the police first discovered
pieces of the victim miss leiden's
remains in the early hours of march 3rd
when a 911 caller reported that they had
found body parts in a shopping cart
outside of a pawn shop at the corner of
atlantic and pennsylvania avenues in
brooklyn police officers arrived to find
a woman's torso inside a multi-colored
bag with a flower decal
and they also by the way discovered the
um
the the the killer was uh rolling around
a grocery cart a grocery store in one of
those carts and was sitting on top
apparently of the severed leg
of uh of the victim
now that's where we're beginning and i
said it only gets worse the deeper you
go so
you know you're in for a bumpy ride with
this as the starting point
it turns out that the suspect last name
marceline
is an actual serial killer having been
twice convicted already of murdering two
other women that we know of on two
separate occasions so the times
continues
miss marcelin has served decades in
state prison in connection with two
manhattan homicides in 1963 and 1984. in
october 1963 she was convicted of
first-degree murder for fatally shooting
her then girlfriend in a harlem
apartment building
the state court judge overseeing the
case imposed a life sentence after the
jury was unable to decide whether to
impose the death penalty court filing
show in may 1984 miss marslin was
released from prison on lifetime parole
according to state records less than a
year later after her body was found in a
bag near central park manhattan
prosecutors said miss marslin had
stabbed to death another woman that she
had been living with in 1986 she pleaded
guilty to first degree manslaughter was
sentenced to six to 12 years in prison
state records show because of her parole
status that sentence was added to the
original life term over the next three
decades she repeatedly sought release on
parole and was denied in a 1997
appearance before the state parole board
miss martin described the 1984 crime and
said she had problems with women
in 2010 the state denied another bid for
parole
saying your release at this time is
incompatible with the welfare and safety
of the community but then she was
released on parole in 2019 record show
okay so
marceline killed a woman
first-degree murder
sentenced to life in prison but was
released after 20 years
marceline kills another woman
is sentenced to prison
added on to the original life sentence
is released again
even though the parole board had
previously said that it would be unsafe
for society if we release you they
released them anyway
and then uh and then uh the killer
proceeds to kill and dismember a third
victim
that we know of
so apparently big shocker here a serial
killer does not magically become less
dangerous and less deranged after
sitting in a cage for a few decades
there does not arrive a point where you
can say well this deranged lunatic
psychopath killer has been stewing in
solitary confinement for 18 years i'm
sure they're normal now right
that doesn't doesn't happen it doesn't
work that way
um and yet the killer was released again
to kill again but we're missing one
detail here
so you've um you've probably already
maybe noted something
you thought probably well a female
serial killer that's that's unusual it's
not unheard of but it's unusual
you don't hear very many of those
and a female serial killer who targets
women now now that probably is unheard
of
but then the new york times offers this
detail
miss marceline who was listed as male in
earlier court records but now identifies
as a woman according to a law
enforcement official was indicted on
second-degree murder charges on thursday
in the death of susan lydon
accused of dismembering her and hiding
her body parts okay so
this demented psychopath who dismembers
women also happens to have a fetish
where he likes to pretend to be a woman
and the new york times not to mention
the cops the court system
everybody
they're all making sure to respect
this lunatic's delusional fetish and
even participate in it
this is some straight up buffalo bill
silence of the lamb stuff
where this guy likes to kill women and
essentially assume their identity
it should be very clear to any rational
person that his quote gender identity in
this case is all part and parcel with
the whole psychopathic routine
and even if it isn't i mean even if his
masquerading as a woman has nothing to
do with his murder of women even if even
if he developed these two uh quirks
independently
still why should we care to respect his
pronouns
the whole argument for respecting
someone's pronouns is that we don't want
to hurt their feelings i think that's a
bad argument
in general
but for a serial killer
we're actually worried about hurting his
feelings
now this is one example
an extreme example uh but also not
unprecedented of a problem that
permeates our society
which is that
we don't tell people no
you know we're not allowed to say no
anymore nobody says no we're so allergic
to know
that we won't even say it to a damn
serial killer who asks us to affirm his
alleged gender identity a gender
identity that it just so happens
will presumably mean that this killer of
women will now be put in a women's
prison
again any reasonable person can see that
this is almost certainly why he is
calling himself a woman so that he can
be housed with women
his prey of choice
and rather than saying no we're not
doing that you're going to a male prison
you freaking lunatic
the instead the court system will say
well okay we respect that i mean we
don't approve of other things you've
done but we'll respect you here
they won't tell him no the parole board
wouldn't tell him no
the parole board told him uh you're
dangerous to society but uh okay you can
go
now the media won't tell him no the
police won't tell him the prison system
won't tell him no
this guy should get a no delivered to
him by a firing squad but he won't get
that either
nobody wants to say no and we see this
problem all over society not just with
transgender serial killers
on friday we played a clip of a morbidly
obese plus size model test holiday model
in quotes there i put model in quotes
the same way we've got to put women in
quotes when talking about the serial
killer but
um this plus-sized quote-unquote model
who who though clearly weighing
somewhere in the neighborhood of 400
pounds claims to be anorexic and attends
weekly therapy sessions with a counselor
who affirms that perception you know she
apparently thinks that that that when
she's when she's chowing down the two
seconds between bites
count as deprivation and starvation
like i'm anorexic because i'm not
literally eating it literally every
second of the day
that's what she thinks and she's
affirmed in that view she's told yes she
she goes to a dietitian
a dietitian once a week
her dietitian should be well telling her
to go on a diet
but diets mean less food and that means
telling her no and you can't do that
everywhere you look you see people who
have never been told no
you see the the plump fruit of our
culture's refusal to say no our
obsession with affirmation
every person you see walking around with
purple hair and a million piercings
demanding to be referred to as they or
zur or
or zeus or whatever is yet another
testament to our unfortunate habit of
affirming everyone in everything all the
time
speaking of people who should be told no
i'm currently in atlanta preparing to
speak to uh at georgia tech tonight in
the lead up to the women's swimming
championships where biological male leah
thomas will compete
now i'll be talking among other things
about the beauty and value of the word
no now leah thomas is obviously not a
serial killer but he benefits from the
extreme ideologically fueled
permissiveness
in our culture and the primary victims
of that relentless affirmation happen to
also be women
i'll be speaking up in protest of his
participation and also to explain why
it's wrong
and to make some points that go beyond
sports because this isn't about sports
fundamentally this is really about truth
and about
learning to say no
no to the nonsense because we all know
that it is nonsense even most of of them
on the left know that it's nonsense
and yet we're supposed to cooperate with
it anyway we're supposed to abandon all
at once the fundamental truth that all
of us know
and have always known
and and we're supposed to do it for no
other reason than the fact that it will
hurt leah thomas's feelings if we don't
and of course his feelings are the only
feelings that matter
his feelings and the feelings of other
trans people i guess i should clarify i
say we don't tell people no anymore it's
only certain people we don't say no to
if you belong to certain categories you
don't get to know
now the other women on his team they get
they get a no
because because his feelings for some
reason are supposed to outweigh the
feelings of women who don't want their
sports destroyed who don't want their
privacy invaded who don't want their
very identities appropriated and stolen
and cheapened and turned into a
a costume
the feelings of a million women
are dust
when stacked up against the feelings of
one gender confused man
all of reality is dust
the truth is dust biology everything all
of it is to be discarded for one trans
person's feelings
well i think the answer to that should
be no
i urge everyone to say no don't affirm
what you know are lies don't cooperate
with what you know is wrong
don't abandon what you know is true
don't pretend to believe what you don't
believe
it takes some courage to say no in this
world it's a word that's not said nearly
enough
a word that a guy like leah thomas has
probably never heard in his life
but he needs to hear it
all of the gender ideologues need to
hear it
all of the liars and frauds trying to
push and coerce and shame us
into surrendering our common sense in so
many areas of life
all of the cry bullies using emotional
blackmail because they have no arguments
everyone demanding that we pretend to
believe what we don't believe
pretend what is true what is not true
all of them everywhere need to hear it
no
that's the word
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you've heard plenty about inflation
of course and the thing is when when
inflation is at seven percent like it is
now thanks to biden um the paper money
in your wallet is losing value and it's
losing value fast you can just feel it
like you should if you have money in
your wallet you should just feel it
getting lighter by the second um today
an ounce of gold though is worth
nineteen hundred dollars it was worth
about three three hundred an ounce in
two thousand so i've been telling you
for a while now that you can buy gold
from birch gold it's your hedge against
inflation it's your protection against
all the the madness happening in the
economy right now but did you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation buy silver from birch gold
don't let the name confuse you and get
silver as well silver is also considered
real money and historically speaking
it's extremely undervalued right now
it's an industrial metal that's in high
demand for everything from electric cars
to solar panels demand is only going to
rise and some analysts suggest that
there's an unusual dislocation and price
that may present very real opportunities
for silver to rally over the next two
years regardless silver like gold is
never going to zero the american dollar
it's currently going into the toilet
while precious metals are rising in
value so real simple call here call
birch gold they're the only company i
trust don't wait start diversifying
today text walsh to 98 9898 to get a
free info kit on buying gold or silver
in a tax sheltered account there's no
obligation to get this info text walsh
to 98 98 98 to get your free info kit
now well we'll start uh here as mentions
i'll be speaking on georgia tech tonight
looking forward to that um journalist
andy noe has the scoop here as he's you
know of course his uh part of what he
does so well is keeping track of antifa
and what what they're up to so i learned
from him today he's got the he put the
tweet out
it says the atlanta georgia cell of
antifa is using twitter to try and
organize a direct action to stop matt
walsh's speaking event today at georgia
tech one of the strategies so far by an
in an antifa furry member is to hoard
all the tickets with fake sign ups
so this is a this is someone who's in
antifa and they're also a furry
and those things often go hand in hand
by the way
not to harp on it or anything but uh
speaking of people who've never been
told no you know furry that's that's
another example of what happens when
you've got someone their whole life like
no one has ever sat them down and said
no stop this this is insane what the
hell is wrong with you no one's ever
said that and so now these are adults
running around in furry costumes doing
god knows what
um in any case so the atlanta antifa
cell they tweeted this is what they
tweeted heads up transphobic
propagandist matt walsh is speaking on
georgia tech campus tomorrow evening in
an event sponsored by the far right
leadership institute in turning point
usa
if tech students are organizing a
counter we'd be happy to boost to boost
it reach out
um
and then some other antifa members are
saying that uh they're gonna that now
they're they're trying to buy up all the
tickets
so that there won't be room for actual
you know for people actually want to
listen to the talk i say buy the tickets
tickets are free of course we're not
going to sell tickets to an event like
this um but we do you know you have to
register ahead of time because there's
only there's only so much room in the
room
and so their tactic and we saw them do
this
and down at university of north texas
um where they
got in there first however i don't know
if they registered ahead of time or what
for that particular talk but they got in
there first and they were the only ones
in the room all the people that wanted
to get to the talk couldn't get in
and then they just shut the talk down by
chanting and screaming and spitting and
doing all this kind of stuff so that's
their plan that's what they're gonna try
to do tonight now they're gonna run into
some problems trying to do it to me um
for a few reasons one of them being that
you know i think we had so far we have
something like 700 people trying to
register for this event there's only
there's you know like room for less than
half of that in the room so um if they
want to if they want to keep everybody
out they're gonna have they they would
have to organize and take up a lot of
these registrations which
i don't think they've been able to do
but we'll see
but the other thing is listen
it doesn't matter what they do and i
want you to understand this okay
if you're in antifa or you're on the
left or whatever you don't like the fact
that i'm coming to speak at georgia tech
you don't like the fact that i'm coming
to speak anywhere else and i've got a
whole college tour coming up this this
spring i'll be going down by the way the
university of north texas where all that
madness happened
i promised you i told you i'm going to
go and i'm going to go and i will be
there probably sometime in april we're
working out the details right now and
i'll let you know more about that soon
but
um i'm coming to speak at these events
and you don't want me there well i just
want you to know there's literally
nothing you can do to stop it
i will be there and i will say my peace
no matter what you do i will still be
there and i will still say what i came
to say one way or another
you start making a scene and i gotta
wait for you to get carried out of the
room by cops that's fine and then i'll
just resume like there's there's you can
make an ass of yourself you can make a
fool of yourself
that that you can do all that
but you can't stop me from speaking it's
not going to happen
cannot happen
now the other option that you could try
i guess i'll give the same challenge to
antifa that i give to
every you know any any college campus i
go to because there is a q a session
afterwards so
uh
if
i i'll make the same deal in fact i'll
go even farther this time
if you're on the left
and you show up to this event
and you can
provide a definition of the word woman
that is coherent
and that is also consistent with your
left-wing ideology with gender ideology
like if you could give a gender ideology
consistent definition of woman that's
also coherent to make sense if you can
do that
then i will
retire from public speaking on the spot
i will renounce my conservative
ideals
i will pledge allegiance
to the antifa flag right then and there
if you can do that
that's the deal
let's see
um
all right so war continues to
rage
in europe
you might be feeling a little bit uneasy
right now but uh if you are take heart
just know that our enemies around the
world are shaking in fear terrified to
realize
that our military has far
far superior lgbtq initiatives
you know that's we've got them beat and
i can imagine
over in russia and china and across the
world
they're looking at this and they're
saying to themselves
um look
there's only so much we can get away
with
because these americans over there
i mean they've got so many lgbtq
initiatives in their military that we we
just can't compete
i mean look how inclusive they are look
look at the tolerance
they will crush us with their tolerance
and inclusivity
so here's a reassuring tweet from under
secretary of the air force gina
ortiz-jones
she tweeted out said great conversation
with our lgbtq initiatives team
they're asking the hard but necessary
questions that will ultimately make us a
stronger more inclusive department of
the air force
and yes again this was tweeted march
10th so that was you know a couple days
ago
of this year and so this is while this
is all going on
in europe this is what they're doing
then you can see unfortunately we don't
get it we don't get a this was a zoom
meeting that they had
and we don't have a clip of that meeting
as much as i'd love to see it but you
could see the um
you could see the people are
participating in it and there's someone
there you know uh standing in front of
the uh the the pride flag
not just the pride flag but the new the
newest most updated and also ugliest
pride flag which is saying something
and this is what they're focusing on now
probably shouldn't need to explain this
i guess but
but i will anyway or really reiterate
because any time i bring this up and i
tweeted this out yesterday and um
there were people saying well hey
it doesn't matter
because whether you're
gay straight lesbian
transgender you could actually be a
furry i mean even even then
there's no reason why with modern with
the way wars are fought in modern
society
there's no reason why that would detract
from our military readiness
there's a reason why you can't be a
drone pilot
right no reason why you can't the way
someone put it well like you still push
a button and launch a missile right
because it's as simple as that
apparently
um
but the problem is that number one
fighting war is not quite as simple as
that despite how it may seem in video
games even in modern times but also
it's
the point is if this has to be explained
it's a matter of priorities
okay so the question is what are you
prioritizing
what is what's your what's your mission
statement
and that matters a lot in any
organization
what lies at the core of your
organization what are you focused on
primarily
now there might be there are plenty of
organizations that don't really have
anything at the core
and those are the organizations that
tend to fall apart they're they're
ineffective
or they can only be effective for so
long because there's nothing sort of
holding it all together
and so again any any institution any
organization uh private sector or public
you got to know what's at the core
what are we all here for what are we
doing
what what matters the most
to us
and the people running these
institutions have to know that because
that's also going to determine who they
recruit who they bring in
and the problem right now is that
the people
in charge
okay the people
running the military to include
civilians and bureaucrats and everything
for them
they've decided
as a as a top-down decision this is not
a this is not a
a criticism
of the the actual people in the military
who are doing the fighting but the
top-down decision
that at the core of the military they've
decided it's going to be things like
inclusiveness
tolerance
diversity
um you know lgbt affirmation
that's the problem
that cannot be at the core of your
military that cannot be the mission
statement
the mission has to be and the mission
for every military that's ever existed
on the earth until now has been to
defend your homeland and kill the enemy
and when that's your mission when you
understand that is your core mission
then the other thing is you're going to
be recruiting people who are the best at
that that's what you're worried about
are you very good at defending the
homeland and killing them are you a
killer of the enemy are are you good at
that well come on board if you are
there are some other qualifications as
well but that's the fundamental
qualification can you do that
but now what they're saying because you
know someone like
uh gina ortiz-jones
she's not worried about that
she wants to know well are you
affirmative
you know are you progressive that's what
she cares about
and that is going to severely damage the
organization in the institution
all right from axios a fourth dose of
the covet 19 vaccine will be necessary
in order to maintain manageable levels
of hospitalizations and mild infections
um
this according to pfizer ceo alberta
borla who's on face the nation on sunday
so now we're being told by the pfizer
ceo he's recommending that we do get a
fourth shot
in related news the mcdonald's ceo
recommends that you do get french fry
french fries with your hamburger
the ceo of cinnabun recommends that uh
even if you went to cinnabun this
morning for breakfast you could still go
for dessert tonight that's what he
recommends and so the pfizer ceos
recommend yeah sure keep on keep on
getting those shots
but he was interviewed on face the
nation and he said something that
it's the kind of thing that even now
still if i said it i'd probably be
banned from youtube so i'm gonna let the
pfizer ceo say this listen listen to
this whole clip and then especially at
the very end
uh let's listen
do you think that we will every fall
have to prepare ourselves for a booster
shot with kovid just like we get a flu
shot
i think so any variants are coming and
omega was the first one that was able to
evade
in a skillful way the immune protection
that we're giving but also we know that
the
duration of the protection doesn't last
very long so what we are trying to do
and we are working very diligently right
now it is to make not only a vaccine
that will protect again all variants
including omega but also something that
can protect for at least a year so
you've seen some of that data on a
fourth dose a second booster shot you
think it will be necessary it is
necessary a fourth boost
right now the protection that you are
getting from the third it is good enough
actually quite good for hospitalizations
and deaths it's not that good against
infections but doesn't last very long
but we are just submitting those data to
the fda and then we'll see what the
experts also will say
okay so
you heard them there at the end the
pfizer ceo
direct quote says it's not that good
against infections
but it doesn't last very long
so
uh
that's a remarkable not not a surprising
statement still a remarkable statement
coming from pfizer ceo
um given that he's supposed to be
selling the vaccine it's it's not that
good against infections but it doesn't
last very long and i also love it it's
it's a it's it's good enough on its own
but when you put the butt in there
instead of an i think there's a lot of
significance i don't mean to put too
fine a point on it but there's some
significance to his use of the word but
instead of and
so like you could have said it's not
that good again against infections and
it doesn't last very long okay
but it's not that good against
infections but it doesn't last very long
so the butt makes it sound like
the next part is the upside
right so you start with the downside not
that good against infections but
and then you're waiting for the upside
and the butt is but it doesn't last very
long either so it's not that good
against infections also it it wears off
almost immediately so that's the good
part um
but it's as if he's saying i'm not it's
as if
he is saying
that um yeah this thing is useless but
the good news is it won't be in your
system for very long anyway it's as if
he's saying that
as if
i'm not saying that i'm saying it's as
if he is saying that as the ceo of
pfizer all right let's move over to the
uh the sports world
this from the new york post says naomi
osaka's match at indian wells took an
ugly turn
on on saturday when a heckler made an
appearance now backing up for just a
second naomi osaka just for context and
everything you remember her she's the
tennis star who has been
um
she's a very emotional person
and she has become
you know sort of a mascot for mental
health and she decided you know she
talks a lot about her mental health and
she decided that she for a while she
can't take questions from the
from the media because she can't handle
anyone doubting her or asking any
questions at all i mean
she's a
a star athlete globally famous and she
has
it's not that she woke up one day and
found that she's a star tennis player um
no much to her credit right to become a
star athlete you have to pursue that
with every fiber of your being it
doesn't have my accent so she's worked
very very hard very very intentionally
to get to this point to become a world
famous athlete and so now she's a world
famous athlete because that's what she
wants to be
um yet she cannot tolerate
any questions any criticism
any scrutiny from the public
and that was made very clear on saturday
at um indian wells
when a heckler
started doing a little bit of heckling
and first let's uh it's kind of hard to
hear what's happening here but let's
let's listen first this is the tennis
match and then you can i think you can
hear that heckler and the heckler says
naomi you suck
but let's listen to that
thank you
thank you please
hurry
well obviously some disturbance up in
the stands something's been shouted
okay so from what you can tell
it's hard for me to even hear but there
was one person who said naomi you suck
and
pretty standard
sports heckling going on there um pretty
pretty standard stuff i think you'll
spend
35 seconds in the stands at any football
game and you're gonna hear much worse
than that
um
directed at doesn't matter like who it
is it could be the the best player
in the world they're still going to get
the you suck and again much more
colorful language as well so one person
says you suck the rest of the crowd
starts jeering
at that person not known as naomi saka
they they're they're taking her side
they're taking ayami osaka's side so
it's you know however many people
there's let's say 500 people in the
stands i don't know maybe a lot i can't
imagine that more than 500 would want to
sit there and watch a tennis match so
i'm going to say 500 i can't imagine
that 5 even would but whatever if you
got 500 people one person criticize you
499 are on your side saying that you're
a wonderful person
um
pretty good ratio you think you'd be
able to just shrug that off
um and we're just going to leave aside
for a second again i mean i can't
imagine anyone going to a tennis match
the fact that
like
it just seems so unnatural to be you're
watching
sports and to be sitting there so
quietly
to me doesn't make any sense but still
499 let's say to one
um everyone loves you one person says
you suck
but osaka
can't handle it cannot handle the
criticism from that one
and then she doesn't do well through the
rest of the match and she's very
distraught about it and at the end of
the match she actually um
takes the microphone
i guess the winner was able to address
the crowd but then she comes up because
she lost and she takes a microphone and
starts talking about and is still crying
about it and is talking about you know
how why this hurt her feeling so much
let's just listen to that
i just wanted to say um
[Music]
[Applause]
um to be honest
it i've gotten heckled before like it
didn't really bother me
but um
it's
like heckled here like i've watched a
video of venus and serena getting
heckled here and
if you've never watched it you should
watch it
and i don't know why but
like it went into my head and i it got
replayed a lot
i'm trying not to cry
but
[Music]
i just wanted to say thank you and um
congratulations
yeah just thank you
okay well to be honest i was expecting
something a little bit more emotionally
affecting from her but she's very
very upset in the and she talks about
apparently serena and venus uh venus and
serena got heckled at that same place
years ago and so she she was thinking
about that as well um
this is i
it's hard to believe
that someone could get to this point
in sports in athletics and be this
emotionally fragile
it's it's really hard to believe
because all along
the way you you in order to get better
you have to be able to
endure criticism
like there's
you would think there wouldn't be uh one
successful athlete on the planet
who has not
been subjected to all kinds of criticism
because that's part of of of getting
better and it's such a grueling thing to
be
to perfect your craft in any field but
especially in front of and you're you're
performing in front of people
you know you're in front of an audience
you're a public figure so you would
think that you would just be used to it
by now
um
that's what's extraordinary to me
and yet this is someone who even after
all this time just is not able to endure
any kind of criticism at all and look
here's the thing
as as always with these sorts of things
if the story was just that what you just
saw
a tennis player is insulted by one
person in a crowd and starts crying
about it if that was it then i wouldn't
have much to say about it i'd say okay
well whatever she and also she's she is
a woman and so women are a little bit
more emotional and so i gave her a
little bit more leeway there you
certainly see this kind of thing a lot
more often with female athletes than you
do with male athletes that's for sure
but there's no difference between men
and women of course right and yet all of
the of the crime because of criticism
and everything or most of it anyways
among female athletes but anyway
if that's all it was then i would i
wouldn't have much to say about it but
the problem is in the reaction to it
and the media comes along
and um and says
uh that that actually this is courageous
that we are supposed to
not just like feel sorry for her
even that would be a bridge too far for
me i'm sorry but i i i cannot really
pity you that much
when you're rich and famous and almost
everybody loves you but like five people
don't that's i i don't have a lot of
pity available there are a lot of people
in this world who need pity and i just
don't have
any any left in store for you in that
position
but that's not even what they're saying
they're not saying pity or they're
saying admire it as courageous
somebody who cannot endure any criticism
who cries at any criticism one person in
500 499 love her one person doesn't she
starts crying about it focusing on that
and that's courageous we're told that's
what the media has been telling us
yet more think pieces written
uh there was there was one i was just
reading the indie star by
a sports writer saying
it was something like that the headline
was you know this this event shows us
what courage looks like and what it
doesn't look like and he was he was
making the point that the heckler is not
courageous it's not courageous to sit
there and heckle someone well of course
it's not no one's saying it is but
naimi osaki osaka she is courageous
i just don't see it
before we get to the to uh the comment
section
one last note here
maybe we're talking about what what
courage is not here's what courage
actually is this is from the wall street
journal it says one of the greatest
maritime mysteries of modern times was
solved when a team of explorers said
they discovered the wreck of ernest
shackleton's ship endurance which
disappeared under the antarctic sea ice
in 1915 an international team of marine
archaeologists and scientists located
the wreck three thousand miles or rather
meters i should say
not not miles meters under the weddle
sea approximately four miles south of
the position originally recorded when
the endurance sank
so this ship has been
lost
for
over 100 years and they finally found it
which is really fascinating i think
but i mentioned this because the story
itself is simply incredible if you don't
know about ernest shackleton you should
because he's one of the great leaders in
history one of the great men
um and it's just a damn crime that moore
isn't taught or anything taught really
about shackleton in school
and it is a great example of what actual
courage looks like it's courage on a
level that most of us will never
achieve we'll never get anywhere near
but it's good to have that sort of as
your north star
uh to know where he should be headed so
just to summarize back in the early 20th
century 1915
shackleton devises his plan to trek
across the entire antarctic continent he
wants to travel across it all the way
and he decides to do this because
someone else had already gone to the
poll originally he wanted to go to the
south pole uh but there was a race to
the south pole a guy named amundsen a
norwegian
beat the british team there and um the
british team after arriving at the pole
seeing the you know another country's
flag there they know they've been beaten
and they have to walk back across you
know antarctica having lost and then
most of them die on the way hard you
know they starve and freeze and it's a
horrible thing so anyway shackleton sees
that the poll has been conquered and he
sees that his fellow brits have died
horrible deaths down there and he says
you know what i'll go anyway
only i'll be the first to travel all the
way across the continent not just to the
pole
and he puts together a team that gets on
a ship with the prophetic name endurance
ends up getting stuck in the ice before
reaching the continent so they spend
almost an entire year
in the ice on this ship
eating into their provisions freezing in
the cold finally the ice starts to melt
it's moving around and it crushes the
ship and and it starts to sink that's
how it ended up at the bottom of the
widow c so now now they have to abandon
ship
they're on an ice floe down in the most
desolate region of the world literally
just sitting now on the ice
and they sat there for another two
months just on the ice in antarctica
right finally they realized that the if
the ice has drifted close enough to an
island that they could make a break for
it so they sail 300 miles on these
little rickety lifeboats
up to this island they make it there
alive but the island can't sustain them
for very long because it's bare in the
desolate so shackleton knows that some
of them are gonna have to go for help
closest help is south georgia which is
an island which is about 700 nautical
miles away from where they currently
were
so
he decides that along with the team i
think five people he's going to get on
this lifeboat
and go 700 miles across open ocean
across some of the harshest and roughest
seas on earth
to try to get help and also keep in mind
there's like a small island he's trying
to make it to navigating it doesn't have
gps or anything right so if he misses
the island which would be very easy to
do then he's just going to be lost at
sea and they're going to die of
starvation if they don't drown in a
storm before that
so he goes 700 miles
makes it to south georgia
makes the civilization
and then immediately gets on a ship and
goes back to rescue the rest of his man
it took like three tries and he got them
all
nobody died he kept everybody alive this
is two years stranded in antarctica
um and
he kept everyone from dying he kept them
from going insane he kept them from
killing each other not a small feat
just a remarkable tale of leadership and
bravery
that that everyone should this is like
one of these guys you should be a
household name and most kids have never
heard his name which is a
damn
i say again it's a crime i believe
but there's your bit of monday
inspiration we started with uh you know
serial killers dismembering people we
got a little bit of inspiration and then
we're gonna go negative again here in a
moment but let's get first to the
comment section
[Music]
okay so dailywire.com sweet baby
comments
and
let's go immediately to clip
eight
alright sweet daddy walsh your wish is
my command
[Music]
oh my gosh it's now
i think so he got sweet baby getting
tattoos
and i mentioned like three days ago i
think it was
because someone got the sweet baby gang
custom license plate i said if you're
really dedicated you'll get the sweet
baby gang tattoo
but i said i was joking and i said i
will not be held responsible if someone
actually goes out and does it and so
this member of the sweet baby gang has
gotten
on both legs
the sweet baby me as a as a baby
in a diaper and then the other was a
sweet baby gig right on the front of his
like thighs
for all the world to see
and i think those those are real
those real tattoos those are real
my screen here is kind of small but you
could see the red skin irritation so i
think that tells us this isn't this is
not henna or a stick on tattoo or
something
you got the real tattoo
oh man
well congratulations sir i mean
first of all
beautiful
art okay beautiful body art there
um and i think we can all agree on that
but
i don't i don't know what else to say um
i'm speechless in the best possible way
but i again i will not be held
responsible for that
when you want to get when you want to
get the tattoo removed in six months
don't come asking me for the funds okay
uh well done though well done sir okay
um
let's see
michael napper says i was recently
sentenced to multiple felonies and i was
shown much grace i owned my crimes i
came to jesus christ while i was in jail
and after i was arrested i bonded out i
spent the next three years changing my
life these things happen because jesus
christ took pity on me and changed my
heart the judge could clearly see this
and gave me house arrest instead of
prison i cried when he said that because
i knew i deserved prison people do
change especially if god intervenes
jesse smallett
is not one of those people his sentence
was a slap on the wrist for the damage
that he tried to do he still claimed to
be innocent at the sentencing he lied to
himself and others so much leading up to
the sentencing that he probably believes
that he is innocent um right exactly i
mean
change begins with repentance
and i talk about how you know harsh
prison sentences and i'm i'm very much
if i'm a law order kind of person so i'm
in favor of harsher prison centers i
think this kind of prison reform we need
is putting people in prison putting more
people in prison and for longer is
actually what we need and i think our
the chaos in our cities attests to that
but that doesn't mean that repentance
and reformation are impossible now there
are some crimes where it's either
impossible or we have to treat it like
it is impossible if you're a child
rapist if you're a serial killer then i
maybe you i
anyone i have to believe that anyone
who's alive on earth god can change
their heart but
um the chances are so low
that for basic societal self-defense we
have to assume that you can never be
reformed and keep you in prison forever
but there are many there are many crimes
that are not like that um
and people can be reformed then and
oftentimes are but as you point out
michael
it it has to begin with repentance
and
owning what you did
repentance begins with taking ownership
of your actions
admitting that it's wrong
that's the first step and then you get
to repentance um this with with justice
malet he's totally unrepentant he's not
admitting even that he did it even
though everybody knows that he did
which is why if i was the judge in this
in this case
here's what i would do
i would say jesse
i can give you 15 years in prison by the
law and i'm going to give you all 15.
however
if you admit what you did
and apologize for it i want you to get
in front of a camera hold a press
conference tell everyone you did it
explain the whole crime
admit that you did it
and you can never go back and say i
didn't really mean it
if you do that that i'll knock
you know i might even knock 10 years off
the sentence if you do that
um
at the very least i mean this judge who
gave a 150 days in jail
at the very least
a a requirement going into that should
have been you have to admit that you did
it
and said they're letting this guy that's
why it's all it's all pointless 150 days
in jail you know
he's not
he's not admitting that he did it
there's no repentance he's not changing
he'll get out of prison and you know
what he'll do he'll he'll come up with a
different hate crime hoax he'll do it
again
all right um
let's see
rachel says the most controversial thing
you've ever said uh quote my wife and i
have never owned a microwave how
yeah you know what this is our one
protest against modern society this is
the one thing it didn't start as a
decision like we didn't
it's not that when we first got married
we didn't put it in our vows that we
would go to pledge never have a
microwave we didn't really talk about it
we didn't have any kind of
anti-microwave sentiments exactly
um
but it just kind of started that way
which didn't have a microwave we ended
up not buying one originally and then we
realized that you know we don't actually
need a microwave because whatever your
microwave does there are other things in
the kitchen that will perform that task
probably even better than the microwave
would
and um so now we've just kind of stuck
with it now now it has become a thing
right it's a conversation piece when
people visit our house
we can say you know what look no
microwave
conversations are very boring at our
house apparently
um
let's see
okay one other comment is david david
says hot take americans are experiencing
un exceptional levels of stress
rather americans are experiencing
exceptional levels of stress
unprecedented is a strong term
admittedly but it's important to
recognize that modern first world people
are prone to experience undue stress in
any and every situation
somebody who has a strong grasp of
what's important and who have reasonable
mental health read people who people
before the last 20 years will experience
less stress because they're saying we in
the modern world however are not sane so
we get unreasonably stressed out about
even the most basic of things yeah i
mean you raise a good point i think um
the way that i look at it it's kind of
like if a 17 year old kid goes through a
breakup and is totally distraught and
devastated and practically you know uh
just just
utterly ruined by it emotionally
you know that it's you know that it's
not a big deal and you know that they're
gonna get over you as an adult you know
that and you'll know that they'll have
forgotten about this other person in a
month that doesn't change the fact that
they are in fact experiencing very real
emotional devastation i mean to them
it's real because this is the only life
they've lived and for them this is the
hardest thing that's ever happened to
them and they don't have the emotional
tools necessary to deal with something
like this
but what what makes it so bad
for the kid going through this
is not the severity of the trauma itself
which in the grand scheme of things is
almost nothing there's really no travel
there but what makes it bad is is is his
limited capacity
to handle bad things
and right in his lack of perspective and
so i think you're right that it's
we are all sort of in that boat as
modern people we we're we're very
stressed out we claim to be stressed and
we actually are but it's not because the
stresses are so serious it's just
because our capacity to deal with
even the most mild inconvenience is uh
is so diminished and that's where all
the stress comes from
you know the media loves to tell one
side of every story specifically the
regime approved side that's why we've
taken it upon ourselves to start our own
publishing wing called dw books and
we're excited that one of the first
books we'll be publishing is 12 seconds
in the dark by sergeant mattingly the
book is the true story of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
shooting mattingly a 12-year police
veteran takes readers inside the
department's response and debunks the
lies that have recklessly been shared
with the public
so you know it's going to be interesting
but here's the trailer now check it out
it was very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i knew it was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
got so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
[Music]
you know in a world where voices like
his are censored and stories are spun to
fit the media's narrative 12 seconds of
the dark is a perfect example of how
important it is for the truth to be told
the book releases tomorrow march 15th
but it's available for pre-order now on
amazon so go ahead and get your book now
and speaking of great content if you
missed the premiere of the hyperions
then there's no need to fret the film is
now streaming at dailywire.com that's
where it's going to live now and uh if
you haven't seen it yet here's the
trailer check it out
calling all hyperions
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am this is real
well i want that too
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power perhaps it's time for
someone else to take on the
responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
oh
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
the hyperions is a dysfunctional family
film with an 80s aesthetic and it's
definitely worth the watch so if you're
not a member yet now's the time to join
plus if you join right now you'll be
entered to win a spot for the red carpet
premiere of terror on the prairie
starring gino carano if you win you'll
get flung out to watch tara on the
prairie and get the chance to meet the
daily wire folks and the film's cast and
crew two lucky members will each get two
tickets to the movie plus uh their hotel
flight all that stuff to be paid for so
it's gonna be a great uh a great night
for you head to dailywire.com red carpet
and sign up with code red carpet to be
entered and don't worry if you're
already a member just head to
dailywire.com red carpet to enter now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so those who have been
living their lives blissfully ignorant
of the latest celebrity gossip may or
may not realize that kanye west and kim
kardashian recently split up
uh well in fact if you're a really
healthy person you may not even realize
that they were ever together to begin
with but they were
for nearly a decade i think or seven or
eight years or something and during
which time they had four children so a
few months ago though kim left kanye
managed to be declared legally single
almost immediately thanks to the wonders
of no no fault divorce laws and then
immediately started shacking up with a
strung out cartoon character named pete
davidson
so kim was parading has been parading
all around town with pete which doesn't
sit well with kanye who's been very
publicly attacking pete davidson
complaining about the divorce making
music videos where he depicts himself in
claymation form burying his wife's new
lover alive those sorts of things you
know pretty standard stuff um for her
part kim kardashian has claimed that all
she wants is privacy
and she made this claim while securing a
multi-million dollar deal with hulu for
a new reality show about her life
because we all know that the kardashians
cherish nothing so much as their privacy
which is why they will only sell it to
the highest bidder
now all of this
possibly seems irrelevant and probably
uninteresting and it is at first pledge
but there's something deeper and more
significant to be found if not in the
drama itself than in the public reaction
to it
and that reaction has been almost
universally negative towards kanye west
um everyone especially the media
but most of the peanut gallery as well
seems to agree that kanye is a huge jerk
for constantly you know insulting and
denigrating his wife's lover
um and for refusing to accept the fact
that the marriage is over
you know the general consensus that
kanye west is acting insane
in fact he is insane
and that kim kardashian is the helpless
victim in all of this remember all she
wants is privacy
so naturally she left her husband and
started publicly dating pete davidson 45
seconds later while working out a deal
for a new reality show which will
certainly feature many plot lines about
her love life because she just wants
privacy
um
this consensus didn't seem to change at
all yesterday when text messages were
released between davidson and kanye
where davidson taunts kanye brags about
being in bed with his wife
and even sends a picture of himself
lying in bed with his wife
most people on social media seem to
think that
it was actually very sweet of davidson
because it showed how willing he is
to stick up for his lady
stick up for her by stealing her away
from her husband
and uh you know wrecking the family
and then texting pictures i mean just
what a knight in shining armor pete
davidson really is you know
now i've noticed in this public reaction
a very distinct
what i would say is almost a feminist
streak to it
even among ostensible conservatives who
have chimed in
there's something wrong
i think something disordered about the
feelings about rather about the things
that people are saying about this
and that gut feeling on my part was
confirmed yesterday when i tweeted um
kind of my bird's eye view my bird's eye
hot take about all this and i said this
is me
it's actually totally normal and healthy
for kanye west to be extremely even
obsessively angry about the fact that
his wife is shacking up with another man
it is in fact the most normal thing
about him
now this to me seems obvious
whatever else he might say about kanye
or kim
or any of this we should all be able to
at least agree that it's understandable
that a man would be extremely extremely
angry and devastated and heartbroken and
sad and frustrated that his wife and the
mother of his four children has left him
and what's worse
is now sleeping with someone else and
worst of all
that someone else happens to look like a
heroin addicted carney
but people do not seem very
understanding of that and it's not
because of their preconceived notions
about kanye west or kim kardashians but
it's because of their preconceived
notions about marriage
that's what's coming out in all this and
that's what that's what interests me is
about what all this says about marriage
right
this was made clear as i said by the
responses to my tweet um most of which
claimed that my opinion was misogynistic
the marriage is over and that's it
everyone told me um kanye must accept it
kim is not his property kim does not
belong to him as one person told me
kim can leave whenever she wants for
whatever reason she wants and when she
does it's kanye's job to accept it and
as it was put to me many times move on
there's a woman named rachel greenspan
who's verified on twitter for some
reason
she summarized the perspective of many
of her fellow cat ladies and their
supporters she said referring to my
opinion she said
literally how can someone think this
lmfao this take isn't hot it's
delusional and disgusting and
frightening people are allowed to leave
relationships whenever they so choose
it's actually beyond not normal to
harass and threaten your ex-partner's
new partner period
another woman also verified for unclear
reasons margot harris said time to
delete this i hope your exes are safe
again many other similar comments
now i told margo that
i don't have any ex-wives i have just
the one wife and she's still my wife and
she's doing well
in the interest of being polite i also
said to margo that i hope her cats are
fine as well
now i admit when i looked at her profile
i found out that she identifies herself
as a dog mom so i knew that she gave off
the vibes of a woman who defines herself
by her pet ownership i just i got the
pet wrong so i was very close
in any case what you find in all this is
the view
that marriage vows are effectively
meaningless and worthless
and they can be broken at any time for
any reason
and when they are broken
you don't even you don't even have the
right to be angry about it if somebody
breaks their vows to you
the thing is that uh the margots and
rachels and kim kardashians of the world
they hold this view about marriage about
marriage
marriage vows and yet eventually they
get married anyway
and most of the time they don't inform
their husbands that they feel this way
about the union they don't say hey by
the way i don't actually think this
means anything
they also of course throw extravagant
celebrations for their marriage spending
lots of money demanding lots of fawning
attention
even though even though they're
celebrating a union that they think is
pointless and which they have no
intention of keeping together on a
permanent basis
this is the popular modern approach to
marriage and it's why so many marriages
don't stay together for very long it's
an approach that renders the whole
exercise fruitless and futile
it's all a charade you're playing house
the vows are merely part of the ceremony
that's it it's all pageantry as far as
you're concerned nothing deeper going on
there
well that's not what marriage actually
is in fact contrary to the twitter mob
actually in a marriage
your spouse does belong to you i know
that sounds very scandalous to say and
and in to the modern ears it rings as
something very horrifying but yeah your
spouse does belong to you my wife
belongs to me and i belong to her
we belong together that's not just a
lyric and a million pop songs it is that
but it's also what marriage is
you belong together you made a vow to
each other
now if marriage is not that
if it's not where you where you make a
vow and now you belong together and you
belong in this union
and um
you you know you owe yourself to the
other just as they owe themselves to you
if that's not what it is then there's no
reason for marriage to be at all
what's the point of the marriage then
don't get married if you don't see it
that way
um
i do not have the right
to just up and leave my wife on a whim
because i feel like it and go play house
with some other woman i don't i don't
have the right i don't have the moral
right to do that now
i do have the legal right with no fault
divorce i shouldn't have that legal
right though
no fault divorce gives me that legal
right it shouldn't
most contracts can't be broken by anyone
for any reason without any explanation
or any exigent circumstances
with most contracts if you want to break
them then there's all kinds of
parameters that have to be met and only
under certain circumstances cannot even
happen what's the point of a contract
that has no binding effect whatsoever if
you don't again if you don't think
that marriage binds you to the other
then don't get married
there's no point of it then the marriage
contract the most important contract of
all the one that human civilization
rests upon
why would it be the least
meaningful contract of all
either the vowel means something or it
doesn't
either marriage is something or it isn't
kanye's mistake quote unquote was
thinking that his marriage meant
something but that's not really a
mistake at all or it shouldn't be
and to have this thing ripped away from
you your life torn apart your children
deprived of the intact nuclear family
that they need and have a right to
speaking of having a right to things
your children have a right to a mom and
a dad they have a right to an intact
family you owe that to your kids you owe
it to them they're entitled to it a lot
of people think they're entitled to
things they're not entitled to here's
one thing that that kids are entitled to
they're entitled to an intact family
it ought to and when that happens to you
your spouse leaves you tears the family
apart it ought to devastate you if it
doesn't you clearly didn't take the
marriage seriously to begin with
now i mentioned miss margo's comments
about my exes hoping that they're safe
because clearly i'm a violent and
dangerous man due to my opinion about
kim kardashian and kanye west um
and you know i said that i don't have
any ex-wives but multiple people
clarified
that no she wasn't referring to ex-wives
she only said x's you know to include
ex-girlfriends
that's exactly the problem though
obviously what i'm saying doesn't apply
to girlfriends
the person you're dating has no
responsibility to you
no real commitment
they have the same responsibility to you
that they they have just to everybody
just in general to be honest i mean you
should be i shouldn't lie so if you're
dating someone and you don't want to be
dating them anymore you want to be with
somebody else let them know before you
go and and be with that other person and
just those are your basic
duties and responsibilities you have in
a dating relationship it doesn't go any
deeper than that
you can you can in a dating relationship
you really can leave at any time for any
reason
and if you're the person getting left
it sucks and it's hard but it's it's
your responsibility to accept it and
move on
that's true of a dating relationship
it's not true of a marriage
a marriage is a different kind of thing
and the fact that so many people see no
distinction between marriage and dating
they talk about partners like well you
know just partners whether it's spouse
or girlfriend what's the difference
there's a lot of a difference and the
fact you can't see it only proves my
point
now all that said
kanye's a hypocrite i mean because he's
also shacking up with someone else now
probably out of revenge or spite but
doesn't make it any better so you know
go ahead and hit him for being a
hypocrite
um
fine i'll agree with you there
and point out how they've you know as is
the case with so many marriages that
fall apart they obviously both
hold a lot of the blame here
but you can't go after him or anyone
else for being angry and devastated and
broken about their spouse leaving them
that's entirely normal
that's the most normal kanye west has
probably ever been in his life
his critics are the irrational ones the
confused ones
the idiots
and that's why they're cancelled and
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
valdoski our associate producer is
mckenna waters the show is edited by
robbie dantzler our audio is mixed by
mike coromina and hair and makeup is
done by cherokee heart the matte wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show vladimir
putin unleashes a strike against
ukrainian base along the polish border
iran fires missiles at the us consulate
in irebel iraq and china generously
offers to mediate between russia and
ukraine that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen